♪ intense electronic ♪
[grunts]
Morning, guys.
Here in Karachi but not for long.
Going out to the coast.
Gadari, right? Gadari?
-Gadani.
-Gadani. Gadani.
One of the world's biggest
ship-breaking yards.
Up to 1 million tons of metal
is scrapped per year from this place
and it's not done through machines.
It's done through human muscle,
sweat, and probably tears.
So let's go on this adventure
and check out this very fascinating place.
♪ intense electronic ♪
[honking]
Stuck in traffic.
Crossed the line from Karachi
into Balochistan, right?
-Yeah, right.
-Balochistan right now.
So a lot of security forces out.
Lot of Rangers and policemen.
[music continues]
[door closes]
Salam alaikum.
Okay, guys.
It's starting to get interesting.
Saw a few boats from the car on the road.
and then there's one out here.
Quite a huge tanker.
What is it?
The Aristimo I believe it's called.
So legend has it in 1960,
a big cyclone took place
in the Arabian Sea.
and washed up a large wooden boat here
and the locals dismantled it, salvaged it,
sold the parts,
and then the opportunity was seen.
The locals saw they could
salvage boats here,
sell the raw materials in Karachi,
make a living.
And so this whole beach
is about 10 kilometers.
Roughly 135 different plots of beach
for salvaging boats.
Don't know if there's
any snakes here or not, Balochistan.
Getting here was quite interesting.
My driver said some of
the neighborhoods on the edge of Karachi
were very dangerous
and then when we got into
Balochistan it was a different feel.
Huge Ranger presence.
If you're not familiar with the Rangers
they're sort of like military police.
I don't think it's the army.
It's like a separate branch.
Okay, getting closer to the Aristimo.
Can see the scraps over there.
Think you can see it
in the GoPro in the distance.
Lot of scrap metal here.
It's crazy to think, what was it?
1 million tons of metal
come out of this place.
And so let's get into it,
let's investigate what the story is here.
Oh, wall with glass and a ravine.
Kay.
Might be a bit more of a challenge...
...than originally thought.
There's a wall with glass up there.
And a bit of a...
Ah, sh*t, thorn up my shoe.
Look at that.
[grunts]
God damnit
[sighs]
It's like a knife... [chuckles]
in the bottom of my foot.
Okay, there are
a few barriers to entry here.
Mega thorns, dried out moat,
broken glass on the wall.
So tread carefully and resume the mission.
Okay, guys, we're on
more of an adventure than I first thought.-
For some reason I thought it would be easy
to just sort of get up onto the beach
and see them doing the work
but it's not.
Which is cool,
it makes it more interesting.
Okay, this is like a...
Seems like a road
for the workers to walk to work.
It's not that fresh seaside smell
you might imagine.
Smells like oil.
I'm sure ecologically this isn't the best
thing that can happen for these beaches.
Wow, look at that massive tanker.
Looks like the front...
The front was taken apart
and they got a lot of work left.
Look at all this machinery on the beach.
Wow.
And the sea, the sea looks quite beautiful.
It actually looks blue, turquoise.
Here, we have another boat
waiting to get pulled apart.
[wind blowing]
Wow.
Moments like these, guys...
This is what I love about travel.
Just the discovery, and the randomness,
and the surrealness
of situations like these.
This beach is actually quite nice
and I'm surprised there's no litter on it.
Wow.
Look at this.
[waves crashing]
First goal is to get into
one of these ships and see the process.
Second goal, find an English speaker.
That might be a little challenging,
and the third,
and probably most important goal
is don't get kicked out.
Like so many of the things...
So many of the videos I do, it's...
Do first and then
wait for the "No.", don't ask
because when you ask for things like this
usually it draws a bizarre attention.
There's a guy yelling up there.
Look at this surreal scene.
Oh my God.
Absolutely stunning.
These colors too.
Guy's coming behind me.
Just really want to get this shot
'cause how cool is that?
Wow.
It's like the mouth of a fish.
[loud generator]
Salam alaikum.
[inaudible]
Sir, can I get in there?
In the ship?
You and me?
Can we go through the door?
[man speaking inaudibly]
No?
I look, okay?
[man speaking inaudibly]
Wow.
Salam alaikum.
-Wa alaik.
Sir, can I go inside?
[man speaking Arabic]
Can we go inside?
We go inside?
[man speaking Arabic]
Just gonna follow and get into this thing.
[grunts]
Okay, it's dark in here.
This is what the inside
of an oil tanker looks like.
Wow, before oil...
[man speaking Arabic]
Lot of echo.
They're arguing over
if I should be in here or not.
Acha. (Thank you)
[loud boom]
What's the noise?
-Work, work, work.
-Workers up there?
[Arabic]
Salam alaikum
-Wa alaikum salam.
[men speaking Arabic]
-Salam alaikum.
Sir, we go in the door?
[men speaking Arabic]
Engine?
Oh, they go up the ladder there.
Okay.
The goal is to get up to...
Get up the ladder.
Got one guy not allowing this.
So all the workers were excited,
they wanted to...
They were cool with taking me
up that ladder to get into the ship
but there was one security guy there.
Wasn't having it.
So I managed to let them
let me ask the boss
and the boss is up in this building,
the white building.
And so that's where we're at.
Asking the boss
and I'm gonna put the camera down
because getting a lot of stares.
Oh, I'm gonna keep it up.
All right.
Salam alaikum.
[front end loader]
Lot of friendly workers.
Quite a surreal scene.
Don't know if you're
feeling it on the camera
but definitely a first.
Salam alaikum.
-Wa alaikum salam.
Can see all these parts just sectioned off,
sold to the markets.
I'm guessing all this goes to Karachi.
Um...
[man speaking Arabic]
[hammering and machinery]
[torch hissing]
Those are massive engines.
[diesel engine]
[welding]
[engines and machinery]
[metal creaking]
[man speaking off-camera]
Not allowed here.
-What's that?
All right, attempt number one, failed.
There are 134 of these lots though.
So the goal is to get onto another ship.
Very nice people in there,
very accommodating.
It's just the police shut it down.
I think you can see behind me,
the homes where the workers live in.
So they all work on the ships there
on the beach and then they live there too.
So it seems like its own ecosystem.
Unbelievable though, with all those parts.
All that different machinery.
There's so much that
goes into making a ship
and taking it apart obviously.
All right, back to the driver and then
try to figure out another plan here.
I came out of the ship yard to my driver
and the police were there with him
saying they gotta bring me
out of here ASAP, right now
and nobody gets in trouble.
So that was that, guys.
That was a little flirtation with the ship
deconstruction in Balochistan, Pakistan.
Until next one.
And the third,
and probably the most important goal
is don't get kicked out.
[waves crashing]